researchers from the California
Institute of Technology in Pasadena have
discovered a brand new species of
parasitic bacteria that may play a role
in gum disease because it lives in human
saliva and a recent poll suggests
Americans expect pizza delivery drones
by the year 2036 which isn't nearly soon
enough Vsauce Kevin here this is my blow
geologists are making their own lava to
generate and study explosions
scientist from the University of Buffalo
are eager to understand how the
interactions of molten rock and water
sometimes cause massive explosions and
sometimes don't their recipe for lava
includes basalt a magnetic induction
furnace that heats up to 2500 degrees
and after three to four hours results in
10 gallons of lava they pour it into a
gravel formation and inject water before
it forms a crust to help learn about the
dangers of volcanoes near oceans lakes
and ice how do you get this job the path
to sustainable roads may be paved with
pig manure with 43 billion gallons of
swine manure generated every year
researchers at North Carolina
Agricultural and technical State
University have created a pig manure
sticky binder that can make as Fault at
only 56 cents per gallon it's much
cheaper than petroleum and the manure
stink is filtered out during processing
the hope is for this bio adhesive to
prevent manure from getting into water
supplies and making people sick and
instead put it to use on the pig poop
highway using the last bit of shampoo
may no longer be a struggle while bottle
coatings to help the flow of food have
existed for a while
self has been more difficult to do to
its surface tension so a new plastic
bottle lining developed at Ohio State
University features a microscopic
coating of y-shaped
structures these structures then hold
the soap droplets above tiny pockets of
air preventing it from touching the
bottle allowing it to glide smoothly
into your luxurious hair or onto your
luxurious body being called a birdbrain
may now be a compliment thought to have
lower information processing capacity
because of their size avian brains were
found to have significantly denser
concentrations of neurons than mammals
large parrots can have the same or even
more forebrain neurons than monkeys with
larger brains allowing them to make and
use tools solve problems recognize
themselves in mirrors and plan for their
future needs
you can follow the biggest fish in the
world online Conservation International
scientists in Indonesia are using
satellite transmitters attached to the
dorsal fins of whale sharks to study
their migratory movements and diving
behavior the real-time map allows anyone
to see where moby mich or any of the
currently unnamed whale sharks are
located Moby's diving record is more
than a mile beneath the surface and
they've learned that while the whale
sharks are mostly home bodies have taken
mysterious road trips one of which was
2000 485 miles and they know that it
wasn't for mating uh so yeah they don't
know why the gear controller allows
gamers to play using their feet Jorge
LaVey a devoted gamer lost both of his
hands in 2011 due to a meningitis
infection he and two other grad students
from john hopkins designed a game
interface capable of being operated by
the players lower limbs three sensors
under the padding of the sandal light
controller detect foot movements like
tilting or raising the heel which are
then translated to different commands in
the game so far they've successfully
played counter-strike Fallout 4 and
World of Warcraft finally 3.9 billion
years ago a monster black hole shredded
a star and echoes of x-rays which first
reached Earth on March 28th 2011 have
been used to map the black hole's discs
researchers realized they were
witnessing the aftermath of a tidal
disruption event a star ripped apart by
the monster black hole at the galaxy's
center some of the stellar material fell
toward the black hole forming an
accretion disk and a jet pointed in our
direction
I'm gonna leave it with a programmable
and customizable walking robot named
Marty and as always thanks for watching
you see the heterodyne for feeding back
into the stimulus reaction activators
causing non synapse with the motor
control resistor units oh that's good
nah lady that's bad but your
degenerative circuits are torn too
synchronously and that causes
concatenation in the intermediate
amplifiers well that's bad isn't it no
that's good
everyday in our homes and offices as
well as in our motor cars hundreds of
these little robots are doing more
things for us than we realize
taking care of the routine tasks and
leaving us free to live and work and
play in greater ease and comfort and
safety
I'm extremely excited to announce the
launch of the Curiosity box something
Michael Jake and I have been working on
for a really long time you may remember
the past couple of years we had holiday
boxes that were filled with exclusive
Vsauce gear and other curious items well
the Curiosity Box comes out quarterly so
when you subscribe you get a brand new
one delivered to your door every three
months
Michael Jake and I are literally working
on every single thing that goes into
these boxes this is ink ink is an
octopus ink is short for inquisitive we
love ink go to the Curiosity box.com to
subscribe there's a link at the top of
this video's description to make it easy
for you so get excited get the curiosity
box a portion of the proceeds goes to
Alzheimer's research so if you love
amazing things you love brains you love
ink go check it out